[Music]
welcome back to the harbor unboxed i'm
really not sure how to start this video
i was gonna do a fun little gag mocking
the 6500 xt before completely tearing
into it
but this thing is just so bad it it's
really spot the mood for me so i'll cut
right to it this in my opinion is the
worst gpu release i can remember and
i've been doing this job for over two
decades maybe there was something worse
along the way but i can't remember
anything being this bad i'm sure there
was stuff like the ddr4 version of the
gt 1030 that could certainly be
considered far worse as that was a
disgusting anti-consumer act by nvidia
but as far as new product releases go i
can't think of anything worse the radeon
rx 6500 xt is just so bad i
don't even know where to begin i know
i'm kind of doing this review in reverse
this stuff's probably meant to be
included in the conclusion but yeah damn
i'm just so flawed by amd here and
there's no one reason for why the 6500
xt is terrible it's a combination of
reasons just bad decisions that all
point to amd just taking advantage of
the current market and therefore abusing
gamers in the process
in a nutshell the 107 millimeter squared
navi 24 die that the 6500 xt is based on
was originally intended for use in
laptops and probably wouldn't have made
its way to desktop
and if it did it certainly wouldn't have
at the 200 price point think more like
rx 550 replacement but due to the
current market conditions amd's decided
to uh for lack of a better word cash in
and they're doing so with a product that
makes no sense on the desktop at least
at this price point and worse still in
most ways worse than products that have
occupied this price point for half a
decade the key issues with the 6500 xt
are this it's limited to just pci
express times 4 bandwidth which is a
major issue and you'll see why shortly
it also comes with just 4 gigabytes of
vram and there's no 8 gigabyte option
hardware encoding isn't supported so you
can't use relive to capture gameplay
which for me personally is a complete
deal breaker and because it was intended
for use in laptops just two display
outputs are supported and all this for a
200 us msrp which will probably end up
being more like 300 u.s at best after
the initial run of msrp cards disappear
of course which is likely to happen
shortly after release by people who
probably didn't watch my review
now amd claims that these sacrifices
needed to be made in order to get the
die size as small as they have which has
allowed them to hit the 200 price point
which we believe is a bit of a lie and
really even if it isn't it's just hard
to justify releasing a product there's
technically worse actually it's just all
around worse than products that you've
had out in the market for five years now
as well as products from your competitor
anyway at this point i should probably
just show you how
underwhelming the gaming performance is
which as i've said is just one of the
many problems with this uh
this abomination for testing i'm using
our ryzen 959 50x gpu test system and
yes i know no one is going to pair a
budget graphics card with this cpu but
of course that isn't the point we're
testing gpu performance and therefore
wish to avoid introducing a cpu
bottleneck which would skew the data
but needless to say the results would be
the same for these lower end gpus with a
ryzen 5 5600x or any of the new locked
elder leg cpus as for the data itself
everything is 100 fresh for this video i
spent the last few weeks updating our
mid-range gpu results and much of the
testing has been done using medium
quality settings or at least settings
that makes sense for a given title also
please note the 6500 xt has been tested
using both pci express 4.0 and 3.0 on
the same motherboard i've simply toggled
between the two specifications in the
bios
finally i've tested at 1080p and 1440p
but for this video i'm going to focus on
the more relevant 1080p results while
the 1440p graphs will be made available
to patreon and floatplane members
okay
let's get into
it starting with the assassin's creed
valhalla results using the medium
quality preset we find that with pci
express 4.0 the 6500 xt is basically
only able to match the 5500 xt
and the 4 gigabyte version of the 5500
xt at that so a super disappointing
result right off the bat it was also
only able to roughly match the rx 590
which is basically an rx 580 which is an
overclocked rx 480 a product released
five years ago now
but it gets much worse for the 6500 xt
because when we switch to pcie 3.0 which
is really what the vast majority of 6500
xt owners are going to be using
the average frame rate dropped by nine
percent and more critically the one
percent lows dropped by 14
that's really a huge performance
reduction and you'll find as we look at
more games that reduction in pcie
bandwidth often hurts one percent low
performance than most it's also worth
noting that all turing-based gpus use
pcie 3.0 x 16. so the 1650 super for
example has been tested using the 3.0
spec and this means when installed in a
3.0 system it's up to 16 percent faster
than the 6500 xt in this game
even if we go off the average frame rate
the 1650 super was still 7 faster and it
was released for 160 us back in november
the shadow of the tomb raider results
paint quite the picture unlike
assassin's creed valhalla which was
tested using the medium quality preset
shadow of the tomb raider has been
tested using the highest quality preset
as this is quite an old game now also
for most models performance is about the
same for example the gtx 1650 averaged
65 fps in our assassin's creed valhalla
test and we're looking at 67fps on
average and shut off the tomb raider
there's also only a 2fps difference for
the 6500 xt when using pci express 4.0
however once again the issue for the
6500 xt is psi express 3.0 and in this
game it's a really big issue again the
gtx 1650 super is a pcie 3.0 gpu but it
has full time 16 bandwidth which does
help to reduce and even remove any
performance bottlenecks but with the
6500 xt limited to times 4 bandwidth
performance falls off a cliff in the
pcie 3.0 mode dropping by up to 50
percent and this is same we're looking
at the one percent lows
the average frame rate though that also
fell by 28 and saw the 6500 xt go from
65 fps on average
to just 47 fps it also meant although it
was able to match the 5500 xt when using
pcie 4.0 when installed in a pci 3.0
system you're looking at more base model
gtx 1650 performance so worse than that
of the rx 570 and for those of you that
were around when i reviewed the gtx 1650
you'll know how i felt about that
product
the watchdog's legion performance using
the medium quality preset is again
rather underwhelming we're looking at
gtx 1650 super light performance making
it a smidgen fast on the 5500 xt and rx
590 and this time pcie 3.0 only dropped
performance by 8
or thirteen percent for the one percent
lows and while that's far less than what
was seen in shut off the tomb raider and
assassin's creed valhalla i'd still
consider this disastrous for an already
struggling product in the pcie 3.0 mode
the 6500 xt was slower than the rx 590
and only a few frames faster than the 4
gigabyte 5500 xt
so another very unfortunate result for
the new gpu amd's trying to convince you
is worth 200 u.s and probably a lot more
than that
okay so quick disclaimer here i've had
to come back and re-update my rainbow
six siege testing i've spent a lot of
time trying to work out what is going on
here now i have tested this game using
vulcan and not directx 11 and i've done
so for quite a long time now as it is
typically the superior api
however after noticing the abnormally
terrible 6500 xt results i tried again
with directx 11 and found performance
using pcie 4.0 improved performance by
14 to 133 fps on average and i believe
this is because when exceeding the
memory buffer directx 11 handles this a
bit better for whatever reason the card
does work better when exceeding the
memory buffer using the directx 11 api
now interestingly that's still much
lower than what you're going to see from
some other reviewers who will probably
have the 6500 xt up around 170 to 180
fps using the ultra quality preset and
the reason for this is the hd texture
pack which i've always tested with
installed so this isn't something
unusual i'm doing for this testing
all previous rainbow six siege testing
has been done with the hd texture pack
installed and this is really interesting
as it highlights the pcie bandwidth
slash vram capacity issue with the 6500
xt
and the reason i've always used the hd
texture pack is because rainbow six
siege is an old game that was released
seven years ago now yeah it has had some
updates but fundamentally it isn't a
cutting-edge title and you can see that
here with gpu such as the rx 590 pushing
over 180 fps using the maximum quality
preset with the hd texture pack
installed and it's also well worth
noting that other 4 gigabyte graphics
cards are just fine the 6500 xt isn't
though here it's gimped by pcia
bandwidth even in the pcie 4.0 x 4 mode
when compared to the gtx 1650 super
which is a four gigabyte graphics card
again there are four gigabyte graphics
cards here which are just fine so this
in my opinion is not an unrealistic test
condition but the 1650 super does use
pcie 3.0 x 16 and therefore the 6500 xt
was an incredible 27 slower but more
incredible and i certainly mean
incredible in a bad way but even more
incredible is the fact that when using
pcie 3.0 the 6500 xt was 46 percent
slower than the gtx 1650 super and wait
for it 53 percent slower than the rx
590. hell it was even slower than the rx
what a disgraceful result for the 6500
xt this is an unacceptable result even
with the hd texture pack and look you
can argue the ultra quality settings
with the hd textures isn't realistic for
a 4 gigabyte graphics card but again the
1650 super made out just fine as did the
rx 570. the 6500 xt is just a bad
product with too many weaknesses to
count
next we have f1 2021 and boy does the
6500 xt stink in this one i should note
that we're using the high quality preset
here and no form of ray tracing is
enabled our previous pcie bandwidth
testing also revealed that f1 2021 isn't
particularly bandwidth sensitive so i'm
not entirely sure why the 6500 xt
performs so poorly here i did re-run
this test multiple times but i got the
same data each time so either this is a
driver related issue or just a weakness
of the navi 24 design but as it stands
the 6500 xt is well down on where you'd
expect it to be typically seen hovering
around the same level of performance as
the 5500 xt in previous tests
now as bad as the pcie 4.0 performance
is switching to pci 3.0 just makes it a
lot worse dropping frame rates by almost
30 percent to the same level as the gtx
1050 ti
ouch
the 6500 xt is able to just edge out the
5500 xt horizon zero dawn using the
favor quality preset delivering seven
percent more performance in the full
gigabyte 5500 xt so
not amazing but certainly one of the
better results it was also much faster
than the rx 590 offering around 20 more
performance in this example
though there is a but here using pcie
3.0 crippled the 6500 xt dropping the
average frame rate to 53 fps meaning it
was 36 percent faster when using pcie
4.0
so for those of you using a pcie 3.0
system which again will be most looking
at buying a budget gpu the new 6500 xt
is going to be no faster than the old rx
570 in this game
moving on to far cry 6 with the medium
quality settings we find the 6500 xt is
delivering 5500 xt light performance
though when using pcie 4.0 it is able to
mimic the performance of the 8 gigabyte
model so i suppose that's a decent
result it also matched the rx 590 and is
therefore delivering 580 light
performance
that said when used in the pcie 3.0 mode
the average frame rate dropped by 17
percent and the one percent low by 23
percent so now we're much closer to the
rx 570 again the 6500 xt it doesn't look
half bad in our pcie 4.0 system but
switching to the 3.0 spec really hurts
performance to the point where i imagine
it's getting hard to justify this
product even when near the 200 us msrp
do maternal is another interesting game
to test with as this one tries to avoid
exceeding the memory buffer limit by
limiting the level of quality settings
you can use so here i'm using the ultra
quality preset but for the 4 gigabyte
models i've had to reduce the texture
quality from ultra to medium before the
game would allow me to apply the preset
so at 1080p with the ultra quality
preset and ultra quality textures the
game uses up to 5.6 gigabytes of vram in
our test scene and this is what we've
used for cards with six gigabytes or
more vram
then for the four gigabyte models we've
dropped the texture pool size to medium
and this reduces the figure to roughly
four gigabytes and this means despite
tweaking the settings for the 6500 xt
it's still 27 slower than the rx 590
which has an eight gigabyte vrm buffer
and is running higher quality textures
granted the game's still perfectly
playable with 98 fps on average but that
level of performance or really much
better has been achievable on a budget
for years now but again this is how the
6500 xt performs when using pcie 4.0 and
then switching to 3.0 again just
completely cripples it dropping the
average frame rate by 53
down to just 46 fps on average an
embarrassment for amd to say the least
and worse than the old rx 570 it's
shameful really
resident evil village uses very little
vram at 1080p with the balance preset
we're talking about a peak of just 3.4
gigabytes in our test so this is really
a best case result for the 6500 xt in a
modern game that said the overall
performance is a joke only matching the
old rx 570 was 75 fps making it 18
slower than the rx 590 and 17 slower
than the 5500 xt
even worse is the fact that the 6500 xt
was 17 fast using pci 4.0 opposed to 3.0
with the previous bus spec dropping the
average frame rate to just 64 fps less
than what you'll receive from the gtx
1650 a gpu i once thought to be an
embarrassment in this segment amd
somehow gone and managed to make nvidia
look good two years later
death stranding also uses very little
vram with the default quality preset and
isn't particularly bus bandwidth
sensitive so here we have our best
result for the new 6500 xt and it's not
exactly breathtaking yes the performance
overall is very good for a single player
game but it's also no faster than the rx
590 and gtx 1650 super
hitman 3 is also another good showing
for the 6500 xt at least relative to
what we've shown so far again it's only
roughly on par with the rx 590 and just
five percent faster than the
underwhelming 5500 xt
but like i said compared to what we've
seen so far this is actually very good
that said when using the pci express 3.0
specification performance did drop by
nine percent and now the 6500 xt is
slower than the 5500 xt and just five
percent faster than the 1650 super so
yeah another poor result here
and last up we have cyberpunk 2077 and
well it's really just more of the same
best case using pcie 4.0 the 6500 xt is
almost on par with the 5500 xt and is
therefore a little slower than the rx
590 then switching to pcie 3.0 drops
performance by 17
and now we're looking at just 39 fps on
average while the rx 590 is good for 50
fps so using pcie 3.0 the 6500 xt is an
rx 570 in cyberpunk 2077
but hey maybe the power consumption has
something special for us after all this
is the first six nanometer gpu and amd
bragged to us how small and power
efficient they've managed to make the
6500 xt
unfortunately while this is the only
real positive aspect of this product
it's not exactly class leading either as
the gtx 1650 super not only uses less
power
but it's also faster compared to the old
rx 590 i guess it's impressive saving
130 watts when gaming so that's pretty
good but i'll be honest i'd take the 590
every day of the week
okay so here's a look at the 12 game
average data and here you can see the
reason why i'd take the rx 590 every day
of the week
we see when using pcie 4.0 that the 6500
xt was still nine percent slower than
the rx 590 across the dozen games tested
at 1080p
that comparison really does speak
volumes about the 6500 xt but it's the
pcie 3.0 result that cements it as the
worst gpu we can recall reviewing at
least in recent history
using pcie 3.0 the 6500 xt was 29 slower
than the rx 590 and 25 slower than the
gtx 1650 super or another way to put it
the rx 590 was 40 percent faster and the
gtx 1650 super 34 faster that's the same
margin you'll find when going from the
480 dollar 6700 xt
to the 1000 60 900 xt
so given that anything over 200 us for
this level of performance is absurd even
in today's market let me show you why
i've got a lot of cost per frame graphs
to go over here but let's start in
fantasyland because you know it's fun to
pretend yes i'm talking about the msrp
if all gpus past and present were still
available today at their original msrp
this is how they'd stack up the gtx 1650
super would be the value king followed
by the four gigabyte 5500 xt
the 6500 xt in its pcie 4.0 mode would
be below average offering similar value
to the old rx 570 and worse than the
terrible gtx 1650 so that's less than
ideal then when re-valued using the pcie
3.0 performance numbers the 6500 xt ends
up being the worst value gpu to be
released in the mid-range to low-end
segment in the last five years so
that's just great news
but what if we look at the typical ebay
sale prices and go with a more realistic
300 us asking price for the 6500 xt
if the pcie 4.0 performance was the same
performance you'd see when using pcie
3.0 then in today's market it wouldn't
be terrible
assuming you only want dual to support
and don't require hardware encoding if
you want either of those features then
you might as well just get the 1650
super given that this is the performance
that particular card offers on a pcie
3.0 system or perhaps better still get
the much cheaper rx 570 which can be
regularly had for 220 us that's an 80
saving on a card that supports full pcie
time 16 bandwidth hardware encoding and
triple monitor support and some cards
even support more monitors still as far
as cost per frame goes the 6500 xt isn't
bad at 300 dollars providing you can get
at or very near to the pcie 4.0
performance
it's just not great but it might be
useful for some and again the problem
really is the pcie 3.0 performance which
kills the value of the 6500 xt making it
by far one of the worst graphics cards
available today in the 300 to 700 price
range
okay so we started in pricing
fantasyland with the msrps and then we
quickly jumped to the harsh reality of
pricing on ebay
but what about wishful thinking for just
the 6500 xt so basically fantasyland
again but for this one product
what if the 6500 xt was available for
200 and in good numbers while everything
else was priced where it currently is
this is about the only way the 6500 xt
makes sense and even then if you're not
using pcie 4.0 it's not a given that you
go for amd's laptop gpu on a pcie card
the pcie 4.0 performance makes it by far
the best value option again assuming
that you don't need stuff like hardware
encoding but for pcie 3.0 users even at
200 us i feel it's still a tough sell as
you'll get a similar level of value from
the 4 gigabyte 5500 xt while receiving
twice the pcie bandwidth hardware
encoding and triple monitor support or
for similar money you can just snag a
second hand rx 570 and again it has none
of the shortcomings the 6500 xt suffers
from
as a side note to the testing just seen
it is worth noting that amd's own
benchmark numbers for the 6500 xt
are of course based on pcie 4.0
performance but they also have sam
enabled and that's amd's branding for
the pcie resizable bar feature so i've
gone back and tested assassin's creed
valhalla with sam enabled as this game
sees between a 15 to 20 performance gain
with high-end gpu such as the rx 6800
6800 xt and 6900 xt
in the case of the 6500 xt it looks as
though sam is significantly less
effective as he were only seeing a 5
performance bump in the pcie 4.0 mode
which i suppose is helpful though sadly
there is no performance going to be had
when using pcre 3.0 at least in this
example so sam doesn't help alleviate
the pcie 3.0 bottleneck
before wrapping up the testing i decided
to take a look at preset scaling with
the 6500xt using both pci express 4.0
and 3.0 starting with the rainbow six
siege data using the vulcan api we find
that it's really only the ultra quality
preset which cripples the pcie 3.0
configuration which i suppose is to be
expected at least in this game so what
this means is if you're an esports type
gamer using competitive settings then
the pcie bandwidth weakness of the 6500
xt is likely going to be far less of an
issue
now i've also run these same tests using
directx 11 and interestingly when memory
limited the 6500 xt does make out much
better seeing when looking at the ultra
and very high quality data while the
high and medium data is similar to what
we saw when testing with vulcan
watchdog's legion is interesting because
previously this game was tested using
the medium quality preset where we found
pcie 4.0 to be 9 faster
but even if we use the lowest quality
preset the game has to offer that margin
doesn't really change and in fact it
grew here to 11
so that means there's going to be at
least a 10 advantage for pcie 4.0 over
3.0 in this title with the 6500 xt
it's also worth noting that if you're
more of a single player campaign type
gamer who only targets say 40 to 60 fps
and has a priority on visual quality
rather than high fps the 6500 xt really
isn't going to be for you at least if
you're limited to pcie 3.0 here the very
high quality preset ran 29 faster using
pcie 4.0 with 44 fps at 1080p opposed to
just 34fps using pcie
3.0 f1 2021 didn't play nearly as well
on the 6500 xt were limited to pcie 3.0
we saw 47 stronger performance with the
ultra high preset when using pci 4.0 and
again those of you prioritizing visuals
over frame rates won't be best served by
the 6500 xt
then we see with the high quality preset
which we've already shown previously
when testing f12021 that the pcie 4.0
configuration was 41 faster but here
we're also seeing it's 37 faster using
medium and quite shockingly still 24
faster when using low
shadow of the tomb raider is a game that
ran terribly using pcie 3.0 relative to
what we saw with 4.0
though i was using the highest quality
preset this saw 4.0 deliver 38 greater
performance and that margin was heavily
reduced to 18
with the higher quality preset then 9
with medium and percent was low
still my issue here is that the game
looks and runs great using the highest
and higher quality presets with pcie 4.0
so dropping so much performance when
using pci 3.0 simply isn't acceptable
you've waited a long time for amd to
release a budget rd and a2 gpu and
you've waited even longer to replace
your rx 460 470 480 560 570
or maybe 580 and this is what you're now
faced with the 6500 xt with an asking
price of 200 u.s which will likely end
up being 300 plus and you know what
though i could have gotten on board with
the whole it only has four gigabytes of
vram so miners won't bite argument
if the rest of the gpu wasn't so heavily
cut down and sure avoiding the pcie 3.0
performance hit or at least
significantly reducing it
will be relatively easy in most games
just lower texture quality
but is that really the point i know some
people are going to make this argument
so i'm just going to head it off by
saying why
why would you compromise on the most
important visual quality setting to head
off an unnecessary performance hit
when used in a pci 3.0 system and of
course with the 6500 xt you're forced
into doing just that but with the gtx
1650 super for example you don't have to
despite that it also only features just
four gigabytes of vram and this is
because it supports the full pcie time
16 bandwidth as a result it was able to
deliver perfectly playable performance
and shut off the tomb raider at 1080p
using the highest quality preset we saw
67 fps on average
so while i know that some will claim the
testing to be unrealistic or
unreasonable it's really not
even the 6500 xt itself was good for 65
fps in our shadow of the tomb raider
test using pcie 4.0 you can't drop
nearly 30 percent of the original
performance when moving to a pcie
specification that can't even saturate
the rtx 3090 and blame anything but the
graphics card an even better example
would be a more modern game like
watchdog's legion which was tested using
the medium quality preset and that sets
texture quality to its lowest possible
value yet even here one percent lows
dropped by 13 when using pcie 3.0 and on
a budget gpu already struggling to
maintain over 60 fps at all times
that performance hit will certainly be
noticed the fact is you can't compromise
on both vram capacity and pci bandwidth
to a degree you can get away with
handicapping one or the other but both
is just disastrous for performance it
also creates a situation where the 6500
xt is overly sensitive to exceeding the
vram buffer even by a little bit whereas
products such as the gtx 1650 super have
a lot more leeway but of course as i
mentioned at the start of this video the
pcie times 4 bandwidth limitation is
just one of the major problems with the
6500 xt
another big problem with this product is
the fact that encoding isn't supported
so amd's version of shadowplay known as
reliv can't be used with the 6500xt
but if you had an old rx file 470 even i
was going to say 480 but even a 470 you
could use a feature like relive so for
me this is a complete deal breaker as i
use this feature not only when gaming
with my friends but i also use it even
for work i don't care if i'm spending
two thousand dollars or two hundred
dollars on a gpu i want hardware
encoding and frankly i feel gpu hardware
encoding is even more critical on
low-end systems that simply don't have
the cpu resources to spare you're also
limited to just two display outputs
which again could be a deal breaker for
some people but the point being this
isn't a limitation of much older
products such as the rx-480 for example
the 6500 xt also forgoes av1 decode
support making it fairly ordinary for
use in a modern home theater pc
av1 content is already pretty widespread
today so retiring this graphics card
into a home theater pc in a few years
time
won't be an option for most hurting its
value even more and this is a feature
you do get on the more expensive rd and
a2 gpus so assuming that you're happy to
sacrifice the features just mentioned
and also assuming that you can achieve
the pcie 4.0 performance shown in this
video using perhaps pci 3.0 by heavily
reducing texture quality and likely
other quality settings
what is the radeon rx 6500x worth in my
opinion it's a hard pass at three
hundred dollars you'd be far better off
buying a used graphics card such as the
gtx 1650 super 5500xt or the four
gigabyte versions of the rx 570 580.
given the gtx 1650 super is a pcie 3.0
time 16 product it's going to be a much
safer bet for the vast majority of
gamers
the 6500 xt in my opinion really only
starts to become a viable option at 200
and frankly for me to buy it it would
need to be no more than 200 u.s and yes
i am aware of the current market
situation frankly i'd rather spend 100
more on the gtx 1650 super to get the
features i actually need and use i'd
also probably be gaming on a pcie 3.0
system if i was in the market for such a
product making the gtx 1650 super the
obvious choice
so that's it 200 or bust for the 6500 xt
and as prices for parts such as the rx
580 and gtx 1650 super start to fall i
have to see rough times ahead for amd's
new budget offering there's not much
more to say really the 6500 xt is
extremely disappointing and its future
now hinges entirely on pricing and
availability paying a hefty premium for
this one is just simply out of the
question i can't help but feel amd could
have done so much better here but it
looks as though the radeon brand is
destined to flounder it's a real shame
given how competitive they've become at
the high end of this generation though
even there they've completely failed to
capitalize due to the supply woes
and that is going to do it for yet
another depressing day 1 gpu review i'm
sorry guys but yeah the 6500 xt
well it is what it is so
if you appreciate this honest take on
this
not so impressive product then please do
give the video a like you can subscribe
for more content i don't think i'll be
doing any 6 500 xt aib card reviews i've
had quite a few companies reach out
their cards were late but they were
wondering if i was doing any roundups i
think at this point in time given
how disappointed i am with this product
i'm going to pass on those aib card
reviews
but of course we will watch pricing and
see how things play out over the next
few weeks and tim louie's gpu pricing
updates monthly so anyway yeah like i
said like subscribe we also have patreon
and floatplane if you want to get early
access to content
if you want to see behind the scenes
stuff q a's
live streams that tim and myself do and
get access to our discord server for
hover and box community members
but if not perfectly fine i will just
thank you for watching this video i'm
your host steve and i'll see you again
next time
[Music]
you